one of the babies coming oh yes I aren't  you nice usually nice what's than my  mother Amal Clooney who is expecting  twins with husband George is not missing  a beat during her pregnancy I think she  likes working the 39 year old human  rights lawyer was out and about on  Wednesday taking care of business on  International Women's Day first Amal was  spotted outside the United Nations  headquarters in New York City showing  off her growing baby bump in one of her  chicest looks yet a dark gray vintage  Dior pencil skirt and blazer with  pinstriped pumps  okay great Asia then the fashionable  attorney popped in pink to attend a  charity event in the evening Amal wore a  gorgeous velvet blush dress paired with  a matching coat and lipstick color well  we can't get enough of the expectant mom  slaying her maternity fashion  [Music]